[Musik]
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Eigentlich wollten wir euch unsere Wochenendroutine zeigen,
aber wir haben einen Besucher. Er ist abgehauen.
Sag mal Hallo, Yoshi. [Aww]
MURAT: Das ist unser Bürohund. Also wir haben selber keinen Hund.
Wir haben einen Bürohund. Der gehört dem Siamak.
Der ist natürlich den ganzen Tag hier beim Arbeiten.
Da wird keiner auf dem Hund aufpassen. Deswegen haben wir ihn hier.
[Sally lacht]
Ja.
SALLY: Aber eigentlich kommt der nie runter. Der ist immer oben mit dabei.
Jedenfalls: Herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt - mit Murat.
MURAT: Und Sally.
SALLY: Ich hab gedacht [lacht], ich hab gedacht, du sagst auch was.
Also, wir haben uns gedacht, wir stehen jetzt kurz vor dem Wochenende
und wir haben uns gedacht, dass wir mal ein Video darüber machen,
wie wir unser Haus reinigen und sauber halten, denn
wenn ich am Wochenende oder unter der Woche zeige,
wie ich eben meinen Alltag gestalte,
dann kommt eigentlich immer wieder die Frage:
"Okay Sally, wie hältst du das Haus die ganze Zeit sauber?"
Ich glaube, viele kennen es einfach, dass sie sagen:
"Wir sind schon mit einer Wohnung überfordert.
Ihr habt ein riesen Haus. Wie bleibt es sauber?"
Da muss man halt schon dazu sagen, dass wir einfach
größtenteils alles selber machen,
aber eben natürlich auch auf das Team angewiesen sind,
denn wo Menschen sind, entsteht auch Dreck - wo Kinder sind, sowieso.
Die Kinder sind bei uns mit einbezogen.
Die dürfen helfen, sage ich immer. Sie müssen nicht, aber dürfen.
Also eigentlich müssen sie, aber ich...
MURAT: Sie müssen helfen.
SALLY: ... verpacke es positiv.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Denn wir leben alle hier.
Was ich immer ganz schlimm finde - wenn Menschen sagen:
"Ja hilft dir dein Mann bei der Hausarbeit?"
Dann denke ich immer so: Er hilft mir nicht; das ist seine Aufgabe.
Er wohnt hier. Er lebt hier und wir leben alle hier.
MURAT: Ich zahle Miete, genau!
Also es gibt hier manche Männer, die haben ein Faibel.
Manche stehen auf tolle Autos, manche stehen auf teure Uhren,
andere haben eine Eisenbahn oder Briefmarken.
Für mich ist das Coole einfach das Saubermachen.
Ich komme aus dem Schwabenländle - da gab's die Kehrwoche.
Und das Saubermachen...
SALLY: Gibt's auch im Badischen.
MURAT: Ja, im Badischen gibt's das auch.
Ich find's einfach richtig cool. Also ich lieb das über alles.
Und vor allem, beim Putzen - beim Staubsaugen, beim Staubwischen -
mache ich mir einfach eine coole Musik rein...
SALLY: Das stimmt.
MURAT: ... und du musst nicht mehr nachdenken,
weil du tust jeden Tag so viele Entscheidungen treffen
und da ist einfach mal cool,
nichts zu denken und einfach nur sauber zu machen.
SALLY: Ja, das war schon in Kirrlach in der Wohnung immer so,
dass er mich mit den Kindern weggeschickt hat. Und er hat gesagt:
"Jetzt geht raus. Ich mache jetzt den Boden."
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Und das haben wir dann auch gemacht.
Also wir haben immer eine gute Aufgabenverteilung.
Jedenfalls stehen wir jetzt kurz vor dem Wochenende
und bei uns ist immer die Wochenendroutine: Alle helfen mit.
Also bei uns ist es ja schon so, dass es auch unter der Woche sauber ist.
Wir machen immer sofort den Dreck weg, wenn er anfällt.
Aber wie gesagt, freitags ist immer so Kaffeemaschinen reinigen
und alle Regale nochmal schön ausräumen
bzw. wegräumen was nicht hingehört,
denn die Folgewoche wollen wir immer sauber starten.
Ich meine, wir leben auch halt hier.
Ist ja nicht ein Büro, was wir nur unter der Woche betreten,
sondern wir wohnen auch hier und sind hier auch am Wochenende.
Deswegen muss es halt sauber sein und deswegen würde ich sagen,
machen wir jetzt sauber.
MURAT: Genau. Und das Coole ist auch, dass es ein Teamwork ist.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Das heißt, alle Mitarbeiter und alle Freunde halten zusammen.
Wenn alle schon am Freitag mit saubermachen oder am Mittwoch,
dann wird's auch unter der Woche nicht dreckig,
weil die sagen: "Oh Gott, dann müsste ich es selber wegmachen."
SALLY: Ja. Jeder räumt alles weg.
MURAT: Hier im privaten...
SALLY: Meistens.
MURAT: ... Bereich und wie wir jetzt gerade sind,
können wir es alleine machen, stemmen wir auch alleine
mit den Kids, mit den Schwiegereltern zusammen.
Drüben später geht's mit Sicherheit nicht mehr.
SALLY: Also im Sallycon Valley, muss ich ehrlich sagen, da bin ich raus.
Da putze ich nicht mehr und ich räume auch nicht mehr auf.
MURAT: Ja, das wäre dann zu viel.
SALLY: Das wäre echt zu viel.
Aber hier okay.
Ja. Also wir machen es immer so, dass wir hier in der Küche
- der Josh, der räumt dann immer erstmal seine Filmsachen weg.
Dann geht es in der Küche los, praktisch Kaffeemaschine ausbauen,
dass die einfach über das Wochenende sauber wird.
Spülmaschine laufen lassen, aber auch noch ausräumen,
dass die nicht über das Wochenende steht.
Dann im Prinzip alles wegräumen, was rumsteht.
Dann alle Oberflächen und dann den Boden.
MURAT: Ich würde euch noch ein paar coole Tipps für die Bodenflächen,
für die Materialien...
SALLY: Ach ja, genau! Weil wir hatten ja auch darüber gesprochen,
dass wir ein Bodenreinigungsvideo machen.
und ich habe gedacht, das integrieren wir hier jetzt einfach
und gehen auf die verschiedenen Bodentypen ein,
wie man sie reinigt und pflegt,
weil jeder Putzvorgang besteht aus Reinigen und Pflegen.
MURAT: Ja. Und da gibt's ein paar coole Tipps,
die ich mir über die Jahre hinweg angeeignet habe, ...
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: ... wo man übrigens auch viel Geld sparen kann.
SALLY: Ja. Und du solltest später noch den Saharasand von den Wänden...
MURAT: Genau, den Saharasand haben wir auch noch.
Sahrasand haben wir auch noch an den Scheiben.
SALLY: ... von den Fenstern wegmachen.
Okay. Jetzt komm, nicht rumstehen.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Hop!
[Musik]
Ich gucke dann immer noch, ob die Backöfen sauber sind.
Da mache ich es halt auch immer so:
Wenn was einbrennt, wird es halt sofort saubergemacht.
Also am besten den Schmutz immer sofort beseitigen.
Aber hier gehe ich auch noch einmal mit meinem Allesreiniger immer drüber.
Falls doch etwas eingebrannt ist, mache ich es auch so,
dass ich dann einfach freitagabends Pyrolyse oder Eco-Clean anmache.
Und wie gesagt: Immer schön die Kaffeemaschine.
Das raus.
[Musik]
Vielleicht habt ihr es mal in alten Videos gesehen,
und zwar, wir haben daheim eine Zentralstaubsauganlage.
Das ist eine der Dinge, wo ich immer in mein Haus einbauen würde.
Das nimmt euch wirklich - wie soll ich sagen -
Dadurch spart ihr wirklich so viel Zeit
und es gibt keine Staubverwirbelung.
Ich tu das einfach hier einstecken
Zack.
[Staubsauger läuft leise]
Guck mal, das ist jetzt - das ist schon die höchste Stufe, die es laut ist,
aber es saugt richtig.
Den nehme ich nur für den Teppich,
weil für den Boden haben wir etwas Anderes.
Guck mal, man hört kaum etwas.
Der Staub wird direkt rübergeblasen und geht nach Narnia.
Also ihr habt keinen Staubsaugerbeutel, kein Garnichts mehr.
[Musik]
[Staubsauger]
So. Jetzt hört es schon auf.
Den Staubsauger verwende ich wirklich nur für den Teppich.
Sobald es draußen mal ein bisschen wärmer ist,
würde ich euch gerne mal ein Video zeigen,
wie man den Teppich wirklich ganz, ganz easy reinigt,
aber draußen ist es momentan zu kalt.
Deswegen geht's grad nicht.
Hier haben wir einen ganz normalen Hartboden.
Der Hartboden - das ist ein Sichtbetonestrich.
Da haben schon einige danach gefragt.
Das hat unser Freund Mortimor aus Hockenheim gemacht.
Das ist ein richtig cooler Boden - würde ich immer, immer wieder machen.
Was ich das nächste Mal vielleicht machen würde:
Ich würde es ein bisschen heller machen,
weil ab und zu bekommt der wirklich ein paar Kratzer drauf,
wenn wir mal so Sachen rumschieben oder Kameras rumschieben
oder Kisten rumschieben. Deswegen würde ich einen Tick heller machen.
Aber der ist absolut pflegeleicht.
Hier haben wir z. B. unsere VIA Platten.
Die haben wir überall im Haus. Ich lieb die ja über alles.
Die kommen aus Bacharach.
Jede Platte ist handgemacht. Das sind eigentlich -
man spricht hier nicht von Fliesen, sondern wirklich Platten,
sind 1,5 cm dick.
Das ist so ein Fries, was wir hier haben.
Das haben wir im ganzen Haus verteilt.
Das heißt, wir haben wirklich verschiedene Bodenbeläge,
Wir haben einmal diese VIA Platten, wir haben diese Hartböden überall,
Teppiche - haben wir unsere eigenen Teppiche hier -
und wir haben Parkett.
Wie wir das alles reinigen, das wird euch meine Frau zeigen.
Oder? Machst du das?
SALLY: Ich mach das. Ich red nicht nur, ich mach!
MURAT: Ja?
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Okay.
[Sally lacht]
Hier bin ich ganz froh, dass wir eine Schmutzfangmatte gemacht haben.
Also anfangs wollte ich sie nicht,
weil sie mir optisch einfach nicht gefällt,
aber ich bin doch ganz froh, dass wir sie gemacht haben,
denn hier kommt ja auch jeder rein.
Hier werden dann auch die Schuhe ausgezogen
und Hausschuhe werden angezogen.
Ich hab die schon alle gesammelt in so einem Körbchen,
damit ich hier saubermachen kann.
Momentan sieht man hier ganz gut,
dass es draußen auch matschig und schlammig ist.
Aber wie gesagt, hier im Eingangsbereich wird alles ausgezogen.
Man darf auch bei uns im Haus nicht mit Schuhen laufen.
Das ist schon einmal Punkt 1, dass es gar nicht so schmutzig wird.
Aber manchmal, ich weiß auch nicht wer,
geht dann doch vielleicht einmal auf die Toilette mit Schuhen.
Deswegen haben wir auch hier - ich sehe es von hier schon -
diese Spuren am Boden, aber die kriege ich gleich sauber.
Wie gesagt, ich sauge hier einmal kurz weg
und dann machen wir den Rest sauber.
[Musik]
Hier haben wir wie so einen Hauswirtschaftsraum.
Also hier haben wir einen Waschtrockner, weil wir hier im
Studiobereich, sage ich jetzt einmal, sowieso nur Handtücher haben.
Die können wir dann auch immer direkt
über das Wochenende anschmeißen, trocknen.
Dann muss man nämlich nicht noch einmal einen Arbeitsschritt mehr machen.
Wir haben hier noch eine zweite Spülmaschine.
Ich glaube, da fragen sich auch viele:
"Wie schafft ihr das mit dem ganzen Geschirr?"
Beim Dreh fällt echt viel an.
Also wir haben beim Dreh locker 3 Spülmaschinen laufen.
Deswegen nutzen wir die hier draußen jetzt seit 1-2 Monaten auch mit.
Die hatten wir vorher nicht.
Hier haben wir sozusagen alles sortiert, was wir hier brauchen:
Reiniger, Bügeleisen für die Schürzen, Bügelbrett.
Hier müssen wir es noch ein bisschen umgestalten,
dass alles so ein bisschen mehr Struktur und Ordnung hat.
Hier habe ich jetzt eine -
ich wollte, dass wir eben noch mehr Zeit im Alltag sparen.
Ich habe lange überlegt, welchen Wasch... [Doing] Ne, wie heißt's?
Welchen Saug...
Wa...
Saugwischer...
JOSH: Wischsauger.
SALLY: Wischsauger! Welchen Wischsauger wir nehmen.
Mit dem sind wir echt zufrieden.
Der Murat hat den vor ein paar Monaten eigentlich schon -
ja, der hat den echt schon seit über einem halben Jahr im Einsatz -
und zwar ist es der Kärcher.
Wir sind auch mit anderen Kärcherprodukten echt mega zufrieden.
Und zwar ist es ein Saugwischer,
d. h., der tut staubsaugen und eben gleichzeitig wischen.
Dadurch spart man eben auch im Alltag dann die Zeit.
Hier habe ich einmal die Station,
sodass er einfach immer schön aufgeladen ist.
Der hat auch eine Selbstreinigungsfunktion.
Wir haben hier, weil wir auch verschiedene Bodenbeläge haben -
wir haben hier verschiedene Rollen.
Das hier sind die für Hartböden, also für Sichtbeton z. B. und Fliesen.
Die hier sind für Parkett.
Ich brauche erst einmal den da; die anderen brauche ich gleich.
Perfekt!
Da habe ich jetzt einfach den Vorteil,
ich habe keinen Eimer mit einem Wischmop,
wie ich es im letzten Jahr noch hatte,
sondern ich habe hier einfach so einen Tank.
Da kommen jetzt 400ml Wasser rein, ein Reiniger
und dann kann ich damit drüben den kompletten Studienboden reinigen,
ich kann hier reinigen, Parkettböden reinigen -
also im Prinzip alle harten Böden, die man hat,
außer eben Teppiche, weil ein Teppich wird ja jetzt nicht nass gewischt.
Das ist, glaube ich, selbsterklärend.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt auch hier den Bodenreiniger mit dabei von Kärcher.
Der ist auch für alle Bodenarten geeignet:
Fliesen, Parkett, Stein usw.
Aber im besten Fall könnt ihr euch einfach eine Schmierseife holen.
Das habe ich euch letztes Jahr im Frühjahrsputzvideo schon gezeigt.
Schmierseife ist nämlich rückfettend.
Schmierseife funktioniert wunderbar auf Parkett, auf Beton,
auf Fliesen.
Schmierseife ist einfach so günstig.
Die kostet, ich glaube, 0,95€ die große Flasche,
und ist auch total ergiebig.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier ungefähr 400ml Wasser,
nehme wirklich nur ganz wenig Schmierseife dazu,
denn die meisten dosieren auch falsch, denn sie überdosieren.
Und dann gibt es eben Schlieren und Flecken.
Wirklich ganz wenig.
Klar riecht jetzt der Bodenreiniger, den man so kaufen kann,
fertig kaufen kann, sehr gut.
Da sind ja auch Öle mit dabei, aber ihr könnt auch hier,
wenn euch der Schmierseifengeruch nicht gefällt
- wobei ich finde, der riecht einfach sauber und schön nach Seife -
könnt ihr auch z. B. ätherische Öle nehmen.
Ich mag Orange ganz gerne oder Zitrone.
Ich nehme da einfach meine Backöle, muss ich ehrlich dazu sagen.
Mache ich hier rein, mache ich auch bei meinem Allzweckreiniger rein.
Dann habe ich einfach eine kostengünstige Variante,
kann wirklich alle Böden damit reinigen.
1-2 Mal im Jahr werden die Böden dann noch geölt,
vor allem die Parkettböden,
der Sichtbeton hier jetzt nicht.
Dann habe ich wirklich einen Reiniger
und der ganze Schrank steht nicht voll mit Fußbodenreinigern.
[Musik]
Ich fange jetzt hier erst einmal an.
Ihr seht auch im Eingangsbereich: Staub, Sand und Steine.
Normalerweise sollte man die jetzt nicht wegsaugen,
denn ein Staubsauger verteilt den Sand und die Steine
und vor allem zerkratzt es euch den Boden.
Also entweder nehmt ihr einen Besen und saugt das Ganze
oder fegt das Ganze auf, ganz schonend und vorsichtig
oder ihr könnt es auch wirklich mit dem Kärcher machen
denn der hat hier vorne diese Rollen.
Im Prinzip ist es auch kein Saugwischer, denn er saugt nicht,
sondern er transportiert durch die Rollen, durch diese Walzen
den Schmutz von außen nach innen
und da ist er dann unten im Auffangbehälter.
Dadurch zerkratzt der Boden nicht. Also das finde ich schon gut.
Im Prinzip, wenn euch Müsli z. B. in der Küche mal umfällt,
geht es auch damit -
wobei ich sagen muss: Wenn mir etwas Großes in der Küche umfällt,
nehme ich einfach ein Tuch und wische es sofort weg
und lass es halt nicht eintrocknen.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein Tipp, ich glaube, den beherzigen nicht viele.
Im Prinzip einmal am Anfang kurz nass machen...
[Kärcher]
... hier oben.
Dann werden die Walzen mit Wasser benässt.
Dann gibt es 2 Stufen,
nämlich einmal nur nebelfeucht und einmal ein bisschen feuchter.
Jetzt hier bei dem Boden kann ich es ein bisschen feuchter wischen.
Nebelfeucht mache ich dann auf dem Parkett.
[Musik]
Die meisten Unfälle passieren wirklich im Haushalt
Da ist so eine Trittleiter saumäßig wichtig,
eine gute zu Hause zu haben, wo man nicht abrutscht.
Das Modell hier finde ich immer super, das empfehle ich auch,
bekommt den normalerweise in jedem Baumarkt.
Ist auch GS-geprüft. Ganz, ganz wichtig.
[Musik]
Schon cool, weil man kommt halt echt in alle Ecken, gell?
So bis an den Rand.
Also normalerweise macht es der Murat immer,
deswegen bin ich grad so begeistert.
Hier.
Hier. Dann hat man ja vorne noch das Licht. Das ist schon cool
[Musik]
SALLY: Können wir die Arbeitsaufteilung in Zukunft anders machen?
MURAT: Warum? Das heißt, ich guck Fernsehen und du machst es?
SALLY: Nein. Das heißt, ich mache ab sofort den Boden
weil das war das Einfachste, was man machen kann.
MURAT: Ja?
SALLY: Und du machst in Zukunft die Küche.
MURAT: Merkst du was?
SALLY: Ja.
Wenn man mal saugen müssen - und dann sagt er immer:
"Ich wisch' und saug' den Boden."
Dabei macht er es in einem Schritt. [Lacht]
[Musik]
Also das mache ich nicht jede Woche,
muss ich ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das mache ich höchstens 2-3 Mal im Jahr.
Hier ein bisschen öfters, aber draußen vielleicht wirklich max. 2-3 Mal.
[Musik]
Endlich. Die habe ich auch gewaschen
in der Waschmaschine. Jetzt sind sie trocken. [Lacht]
Jetzt fühle ich mich wieder wie ein normaler Mensch.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich gerade Nougat in der Hand.
Ich habe gerade einen Nougat auf der Fensterbank gefunden.
Jetzt esse ich den grad.
Aber guck mal, das ist dieser Saharastaub.
Der ist momentan überall drauf. Sieht krass aus, gell?
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Der ist rot.
MURAT: Und so sehen die ganzen Fenster von außen aus.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich den ganzen Sichtbeton saubergemacht.
Jetzt kann ich die Rollen wechseln.
Die packen wir dann einfach mit unseren Putztüchern
in die Waschmaschine.
Für das Parkett nehme ich dann die weicheren Rollen
und kann dann vorne noch den Eingangsbereich machen.
Unser Parkett hier am Eingangsbereich ist ein bisschen strapazierter,
weil da ja jeder mit Schuhen rein- und rausgeht.
Den ölen wir ein bisschen öfter.
Der bei uns drüben oben bei den Schlafzimmerräumen
und den Kinderzimmeräumen - da müssen wir nur 1 Mal im Jahr nachölen.
Also der ist auch echt super pflegeleicht.
Wir haben auch, weil wir mit den Böden hier so zufrieden sind,
alle Böden, die wir hier haben,
also Sichtbeton, Parkett und VIA Platten,
drüben im neuen Haus, also im Sallycon Valley verlegt,
weil wir einfach damit seit 2,5 Jahren
echt gute Erfahrungen gemacht haben und das einfach
einfach zu reinigen ist
und sehr schöne Böden sind.
[Musik]
So. Natürlich mussten wir die ganzen Leisten und solche Sachen
- mussten wir halt noch so saubermachen.
Es geht nicht anders, wird auch kein Mop hinkriegen z. B.
[Musik]
Bei Parkett ist übrigens auch wichtig,
egal, ob ihr jetzt einen Saugwischer habt
oder einen Wischsauger habt
oder mit ganz normalem Wischmop arbeitet,
es ist einfach wichtig, dass ihr praktisch nur nebelfeucht wischt.
Das heißt, innerhalb von einer Minute
muss der Boden wieder getrocknet sein.
Daran erkennt man auch,
ob man wirklich die max. Menge an Wasser benutzt hat.
Denn wenn Parkett länger nass bleibt, und das gilt auch für Laminat,
dann weicht es irgendwann den Boden auf
und er wird eben auch porös.
Die Ecken weichen auf, der Laminat kommt hoch.
Deswegen - hier sieht man auch schon hinter mir,
da, wo ich gerade gewischt habe,
wird alles wieder ruckzuck trocken
und dann weiß ich: Okay, ich habe nicht viel Wasser benutzt.
[Musik]
Jetzt bin ich fertig. Ich zeige euch jetzt noch die Reinigung,
weil ich weiß, dass ihr sowieso fragen werdet.
Also wir haben hier, wie gesagt, unsere Station.
Da steht er auch immer.
Ich habe hier auch das Kabel, wo ich es dann eben aufladen kann.
Zuerst einmal nehme ich den Schmutzwassertank weg.
Der ist hier. Ich drücke immer auf die falsche Seite, aber der ist hier.
Da kann ich jetzt kurz das ganze Schmutzwasser,
was sich aufgesammelt hat, eben kurz entsorgen
und den sozusagen reinigen.
Das ist im Prinzip auch der Vorteil, den man hat:
Der Schmutz wird ja jetzt hier im Wasser gesammelt, das heißt
es ist nicht wie beim Staubsauger.
Ich habe das auch damals bei meiner Zentralstaubsaugeranlage erklärt.
Beim Staubsauger ist es ja so, ihr tut staubsaugen
und da hinten ist ja auch Feinstaub.
Der Feinstaub pustet sich hinten wieder raus.
Dann hat man eine halbe Stunde später,
obwohl man gesaugt und gewischt hat,
einfach wieder eine Staubschicht auf den Möbeln.
Bei einer zentralen Staubsaugeranlage passiert das nicht,
denn da geht ja praktisch der ganze Schmutz
durch die Rohre im Haus nach draußen bei uns in den Technikraum.
Hier hat man eben den Vorteil, dass der Schmutz sich im Wasser sammelt
und dadurch eben nicht wieder entweichen kann,
sondern ich sammle es hier drin.
Ich weiß, es sieht voll ekelig aus.
Ich habe es vorhin auch schon einmal saubergemacht,
weil ich einfach den kompletten Bereich saubergemacht habe.
Aber das ist der Schmutz, der ansteht.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Staubsaugerbeutel,
sondern kann das jetzt einfach entsorgen.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich den hier jetzt reinstellen
und die Selbstreinigungsfunktion nutzen.
Dafür kommt hier einfach noch einmal frisches Wasser rein.
Ich merke einfach, wie hier im Waschraum ein Waschbecken fehlt.
Wir müssen immer zur Toilette, aber ist schlimm, ist nicht schlimm.
Also hier steht auch "For cleaning mode".
Hier die Hälfte mit Wasser füllen, einsetzen
und jetzt hier beide Knöpfe einfach kurz drücken
und dann reinigt der sich 2 Minuten selber.
[Musik]
Die Rollen kommen dann einfach in die Waschmaschine.
Dann löse ich den Tank hier unten
und die packe ich dann einfach mit allen Putztüchern
vom Haussaubermachen einfach hier in die Waschmaschine.
Und das hier.
60°C, dann ist alles wieder sauber.
Der kommt dann auf seine Station.
Hier hat es auch noch - die kann jetzt auch saubermachen.
Und zwar verfangen sich hier praktisch die ganzen Haare
und werden da gehalten.
Das kann ich dann auch kurz mit der Bürste saubermachen
und dann ist er im Prinzip fertig.
Also, wie gesagt, steht er hier,
lädt sich innerhalb von 4 Stunden komplett auf.
Dann ist er wieder bereit für den nächsten Einsatz.
So.
Ich habe meine Pflicht getan. Ich mache jetzt noch schnell Abendessen
[Atmet tief auf]
und Murat zeigt euch, wie wir die Holzböden noch pflegen.
Das mache ich noch sauber.
[Musik]
Ja, jetzt sind wir in unserem privaten Bereich,
und zwar an dieser Holztreppe.
Diese Holztreppe habe ich
oder haben wir mit dem Güni, mit dem Alex zusammen gemacht,
wirklich selber.
Wir haben hier Eiche.
Bei Holz ist ganz, ganz wichtig,
dass man das mind. 1 Mal im Jahr behandelt.
Das heißt, wenn ihr daheim Parkett habt oder eine Holztreppe,
dann müsst ihr es wirklich 1 Mal im Jahr behandeln,
weil durch die Sonneneinstrahlung grad hier im Treppenhaus
wird der Boden richtig trocken, richtig rissig
und ihr müsst diesem Boden wieder so ein Leben geben.
Das, was ich euch jetzt zeige
- ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich euch das zeigen soll,
weil es eigentlich - es könnte sehr, sehr gefährlich werden.
Ich zeig's euch trotzdem, okay?
Ihr müsst nur aufpassen, und zwar Folgendes:
Und zwar habe ich hier einen ganz normalen biologischen
Leinölpfirs... eh, -firnis. Ich wollte gerade Pfirsich sagen.
Firnis.
Das ist eigentlich sowas, wie soll ich sagen,
so eine Bodylotion für Holz.
Damit würde ich alles Holz einreiben, 1 Mal im Jahr,
und auch diese Treppe.
Ihr werdet es gleich beim Auftragen merken,
das ist so ein leichter Ölfilm,
und wie sich dann die Farbe von dem ganzen Holz verändert.
Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz wichtig: mind. 1 Mal im Jahr.
Hier ist es ganz wichtig anzumerken:
Ihr müsst, wenn ihr das gemacht habt,
diesen Lappen wirklich mit Wasser auswaschen,
Ja nicht irgendwo zerknäuelt in die Ecke reinmachen,
weil das kann anfangen zu brennen.
Da sind schon ganz, ganz viele Schreinereien und Unternehmen abgebrannt,
weil die Leute Leinölfirnis benutzt haben
und einfach das Ding liegen lassen haben.
Ist uns übrigens auch passiert,
weil der Schwiegervater hat das mal gemacht
und hat den Lappen draußen liegen lassen
und das Ding hat dann anfangen zu brennen.
Das kann Tage danach noch brennen. Das heißt, wirklich
mit Wasser einweichen und mit Wasser sofort auswischen
und dann ja nicht in den Trockner!
So. Jetzt mache ich da ganz leicht was drauf.
So. Und tu hier die Treppe schön einmassieren.
Man sieht's hier überall: Das sind Wasserflecken drauf.
Das kann vom Reinigen sein. Das ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
So. Jetzt mache ich das weg.
So. Hier sieht man auch diese Ausbleichungen und diese Flecken hier.
Das kann von allem Möglichen kommen.
Jetzt tu ich das schön einmassieren.
Es riecht so nach richtig [riecht] - wie in einer Schreinerei.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich Depp natürlich einen Fehler gemacht,
um euch das hier zu zeigen, weil das Licht hier am besten ist.
Wenn ihr das macht, fangt ihr bitte oben an der Treppe an
und arbeitet euch nach unten,
weil sonst kommt ihr nachher nicht mehr hoch.
Ihr lasst es jetzt auch mind. einen Tag einwirken.
Das heißt, wir können einen Tag nicht mehr in die Schlafzimmer.
Also war einfach...
Ich hätte es euch gar nicht zeigen sollen.
Normalerweise mache ich das irgendwann, wenn wir mal verreisen
oder irgendwo sind über das Wochenende.
Jetzt habe ich es jetzt schon gemacht.
Deswegen muss ich den Kids jetzt Bescheid geben,
dass sie hier nicht drüberlaufen sollen
und einen anderen Weg finden in ihr Schlafzimmer.
Ansonsten sollen sie alle im Wohnzimmer schlafen.
Wie blöd kann man eigentlich sein?
Das hätte man schon vorher wissen müssen.
Oh man ey!
[Musik]
Ich hätte Fitness-Influencer werden sollen.
Siehst du das?
JOSH: Ja.
MURAT: Siehst du das? Das mache ich jeden Tag.
So trainiert der Murat beim Putzen.
Oh mein Gott! Ich kann nicht mehr.
Josh, hol mich hier raus. Schneidet mich raus bitte!
Schneidet mich raus!
SALLY: Schatz?
MURAT: Ja?
[Sally lacht]
Ich trainiere.
Ich habe einen Fehler gemacht, weißt du?
Ich wollte es den Zuschauern gerade zeigen,
aber ich hätte von oben nach unten anfangen sollen, verstehst?
SALLY: Eh, ich wollte gerade sagen,
ich bin jetzt drüben fertig und würde jetzt kochen.
MURAT: Ja.
Ich wollte noch - ich zeig den noch ganz kurz den Parkett, okay?
SALLY: Okay.
MURAT: Josh, komm mit!
Ich zeig dir oben noch, wie ich das mit dem Parkett mache.
SALLY: Kommt der da raus?
MURAT: Kann mir... Kann mir jemand Güni?
Der soll mich rausschneiden.
SALLY: Das ist gut für Rückenübungen.
MURAT: Güni soll mich rausschneiden, okay?
SALLY: Okay.
MURAT: Siehst du das? Guck mal!
Hör auf! Hör auf! [Lacht]
[Sally lacht]
Hör auf!
Oh Gott! Schatz, wo ist der Leinölfirnis? Wo ist der?
Nicht dass er runterfliegt.
SALLY: Ich weiß es nicht. Ah hier, oh mein Gott!
MURAT: Hast du ihn?
SALLY: Ich hab's. [Lacht]
SALLY: Ja, da links von deiner...
MURAT: Ja, warte doch kurz!
Mein Gott, Murat. Wie doof kann man sein?
So. Josh, hilf mir. Komm mit hoch. Ich zeig dir, wie's geht.
Also auch hier beim Parkettboden ist es wichtig,
hab ich vorher gesagt, 1 Mal im Jahr.
Macht es vielleicht alle 2-3 Jahre. Wird vollkommen ausreichen.
Kommt darauf an, wie viel Sonne auf den Boden drauf kommt.
Einfach schön einreiben, aber nur wirklich bei Parkettboden.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Das ist dieser Schutz. Und das ist das, was Sally vorhin gesagt hat:
Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig - nebelfeucht und ohne Tenside.
Das Beste ist hier wirklich Schmierseife.
Das heißt, zum Reinigen wirklich ein paar Tropfen Schmierseife.
1 Liter kostet, ich glaube, 1 €.
Ein paar Tropfen rein und somit die harten Böden nicht nur hier,
sondern auch Fliesen, Steinböden und allem Drum und Dran.
Braucht ihr - das ist der günstigste Reiniger, den ihr haben könnt.
Okay, Josh?
Ich bin aus der Puste. Ich werd noch die nächsten Tage hier brauchen
und den Boden schön wie mit einer Bodylotion einreiben.
[Doing]
Josh, ich hab mich eingeölt
oder halt - ich komme hier nicht mehr raus.
So. Weißt du, warum ich das mache?
Ich will einfach nicht, dass du mich von hinten filmst.
Nicht dass man mein Maler-Dekolleté sieht.
Deswegen mache ich das grad so. Ja.
Okay. Ich, eh, öle dann weiter.
Josh, kannst du mich vielleicht von vorne filmen?
Wäre das in Ordnung?
JOSH: Ja.
MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
Guck mal, jetzt sieht man es voll.
Hier ist richtig so ausgelaugt, weißt du?
Hier hat irgendjemand ein Spülmittel z. B. zum Putzen benutzt.
Siehst du das?
So.
Und jetzt wird er wieder richtig schön.
Jetzt werden vielleicht manche auch fragen,
was für ein Boden das ist.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Parkettboden.
Der ist von Kährs. Der ist ein richtig cooler Boden.
Den haben wir bei KÖMPF24 geholt.
Wir haben bezahlt. Der ist nicht gesponsert.
Aber den haben wir hier. Der ist etwas dunkler
und drüben haben wir ihn auch
und im neuen Gebäude ist es auch komplett dieser Kährsboden.
Wirklich, kann ich nur empfehlen. Ist wirklich nicht der Günstigste,
aber wenn man ein Eigenheim hat und man etwas für immer haben möchte,
dann kann ich den auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
[Musik]
Ich fühle mich,
als hätte ich den ganzen Tag nichts gemacht außer geputzt.
Aber das ist eigentlich nur unsere Freitagnachmittag-Routine.
Also alles ist geputzt. Den Eingang vorne, muss ich sagen,
den haben wir jetzt noch nicht geölt.
Das machen wir jetzt gleich, wenn alle weg sind, denn
es läuft ja gleich noch jeder raus.
MURAT: Ja. Ich bin Ölspezialist übrigens.
SALLY: Ja. Er hat ja schon einmal die Treppe geölt.
Jetzt dürfen wir erst einmal nicht hoch, aber ist okay.
Jetzt warten wir halt, bis es einzieht.
MURAT: Cool. Ich hoffe, es waren viele coole Tipps dabei...
SALLY: Ja, ich hoffe es auch.
MURAT: ... und ihr könnt einiges annehmen.
SALLY: Ja.
Ich mache es dann übrigens immer so:
Wenn ich am Wochenende hier
die Kaffeemaschine saubergemacht habe,
mache ich sie immer aus, damit er nicht dann samstags kommt
und sich hier einen Kaffee zieht,
weil den Kaffee kann er sich dann drüben holen.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Dann bleibt die Maschine schön sauber.
MURAT: Ja. Und unterstützt euch gegenseitig, auch...
Unterstützt auch eure Frau beim Putzen.
SALLY: Unterstützt auch euren Mann beim Putzen.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Cool.
SALLY: Okay. Aber ab morgen ist
Fußboden wieder dein Gebiet.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Denn wir haben schon die Aufteilung.
Also wir haben schon eine gute Aufgabenaufteilung.
Ich mache immer die Küche und ich bin auch so zuständig für
Ausmisten, Etikettieren und Putzen aller Schränke
und er macht immer Böden und Fenster
und - was machst du noch? Treppen.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Also schon eine gute Aufteilung:
bringt den Müll raus, bringt die Kinder weg, holt sie wieder ab.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Daher haben wir das schon gut.
MURAT: Ihr seht auch: Sie kocht und ich esse.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Also Studiolichter aus!
MURAT: So.
SALLY: Und wir gehen nach Hause. Wir sind zu Hause.
Aber ich habe gedacht, es reimt sich.
MURAT: Weißt du, wie ich mir gerade vorkomme?
SALLY: Wie?
MURAT: Wie bei der Tagesschau.
SALLY: Warum?
[Nachrichten-Outro]
Stimmt! Und dann reden sie am Ende noch so.
MURAT: Bei der Tagesschau fragen alle: Was reden sie wohl?
SALLY: Ja. Was meinst du, was die da reden?
MURAT: Keine Ahnung. Die reden dann.
SALLY: Die sagen dann:
Jetzt hast du noch 10 Sekunden. Lächle noch freundlich.
Tu so, als würden wir uns unterhalten. Ja genau.
Und dann kommt so irgendwann der Kameramann: Cut!
und dann so: "Okay, ciao! Ich kann dich gar nicht leiden."
So sind die bestimmt bei der Tagesschau. [Lacht]
[Nachrichten-Outro]